[Music]
[Applause]
okay yeah laureate mercs rock it out
uh-huh
you got one representing up front let's
get this party started all right please
welcome to the stage Kathleen Kennedy
Dave floaty and Jon Favreau
beware the
good morning Chicago
thank you guys what a weekend this has
been don't you think
walking the floor and seeing all the
things that have been created and what
you guys do for this celebration is
absolutely astounding so a huge applause
for all of you in this room because it's
been and outside this room because I
know there's a lot of other people
watching everybody in this room knows
that this guy is a rock star
I have to say what could be more
exciting than Dave Bologna directing
live-action so the fact that John and
Dave have come together and are working
together a Mandalorian I have to tell
you there it this has been the most fun
the most amazing experience and I'm
gonna let the two of them start to give
you a better idea of what this show is
all about well let's start by bringing
out we have some people who made a trip
here in the snow just to be here for you
starting with Pedro Pascal
let's let's also bring out Gina Carano
[Applause]
and we'd like to introduce a new actor
to all of you you may not know him yet
but you definitely will Carl Weathers
[Applause]
let's find out a little bit about who
they play whatever like to be the
mandalorian well just look at the image
that's what it's like
right on the the mandalorian is a
mysterious lone gunfighter in the outer
reaches of the galaxy
I would say his some might say he has
questionable moral character if you're
saying interesting you guys in line with
some of our best westerns and very good
good some good samurai I think that
these incredibly talented men who also
love Star Wars very much have created an
incredible iconic character but I get to
play now we have a Gina Carano who plays
a character yet a character named Kara
dune Kara dune
let's tell us a little bit about the
character that you play Jeana so nice to
see everyone here I had no idea
[Laughter]
I have to say when I got this job I
instantly was like oh my gosh I got to
be a part of a whole another family and
this is absolutely kick-ass so I'm so
glad some way my character's name is
Cara doon and she's an ex rebel shock
trooper I know not what you're reading
online I saw I was watching all of you
playing the character of grief carga is
mr. Carl Weathers Carl yeah Wow well
first I'm really happy to be here as
like amazingly exciting day of all the
things I've been involved in I love you
too
okay of all the things I've been
involved with I don't think anything has
come close to this this is insane okay
this this this this this group of fans
is just like something out of out of
Star Wars actually it's that crazy but
anyway the character is grief Marga and
he is a guy who is running this group of
bounty hunters he's kind of the head of
this guild of bounty hunters our great
group of directors and the primary
prerequisite that they had to be a fan
of Star Wars and love Star Wars
and so for the people who've been fans
for 40 years
we got a lot in there for you that but
these are new characters a new story so
it's a great way to invite new people in
and allow them to get on the
merry-go-round here with all these new
characters too let's make it something
that people could could jump in on who
don't know anything about Star Wars and
enjoy the fact that you came up with
this made it happen and then you managed
to get Dave on Team as well how lucky
can we be sitting here to be a part of
this so thank you - John - Dave and
thank you to all the fans who showed up
for this everybody in every department
would be there for 17 hour days
sometimes right girl
and we're like yeah working on Star Wars
right now so you want to keep us longer
because this is worth it
and it it just had magic the only person
who wasn't having fun was Gina's stunt
double because they didn't get to work
at all or very little because Gina is a
gamer Gina would be doing when John
asked me to come in and and meet with
him about something Star Wars literally
something Star Wars and they invited me
into the room and Dave was there and it
was wall to wall story illustrations of
this series you wouldn't believe what I
was seeing I was born in 75 so I am a
product of a Star Wars imagination I was
shaped by these movies and I'm seeing
all of this and I'm like what do you
want me to do
I'm liking it wait you want me to
audition for the bug or the robot he's
like you're the mandalorian
[Applause]
tonight yeah thank you see y'all thank
you thank you coming out thank you
[Music]
you